mty
food et or burkina faso délégation de
chefs des armées de la cedeao est arrivé
dans le pays hier une mission
ministérielle de l'organisation il sera
dès demain un nouveau sommet de la
cedeao est prévue le 3 février et puis
ira les comptes rendus de ces deux
missions pour l'instant la cedeao
absolument suspendu le burkina faso de
ses instances
[Musique]
la bienvenue sur arte france ravi de
vous retrouver sur le dossier ukrainien
moscou a toujours démenti les
accusations des occidentaux selon
lesquelles elle préparerait une
potentielle invasion de l'ukraine boris
johnson veut pourtant répondre à ce
qu'il qualifie d'hostilité russe il va
donc proposer à l'otan le doublement du
contingent britannique en europe de
l'est et l'envoi de navires et d'avions
de combat d'autres membres de l'alliance
atlantique prévoit également le
déploiement de soldats dans la région
l'ukraine elle appelle la russie à
retirer ses troupes à la frontière et à
dialoguer dialogue toujours en cours
l'otan a pour l'instant rejeté les
exigences de la russie ce détail depuis
moscou de notre correspondant antoine
gayraud
l'escaladé militaire continue à la
frontière occidentale de la russie avec
l'envoi prochainement deux militaires
américains en europe de l'est le royaume
uni va également proposer à l'otan un
déploiement majeur de troupes la
secrétaire d'état britannique s'est dit
prête à tout pour soutenir l'ukraine y
compris des sanctions renforcées contre
moscou et la france n'est pas en reste
la ministre des armées a évoqué l'envoi
de plusieurs centaines de militaires en
roumanie mais voilà pour les autorités
russes et même ukrainienne il n'existe
pas de menace concrète à l'heure
actuelle cette situation très tendue
serait en réalité principalement
entretenue par la rhétorique guerrière
de washington
bratton si
actuellement on dit que la russie menace
l'ukraine c'est d'une absurdité absolue
il n'y a aucune menace les ukrainiens
eux mêmes y compris les responsables
ukrainiens déclare qu'il n'ya aucune
menace
mais non les responsables américains
affirment qu'il ya une menace qui sont
prêts à se battre jusqu'au dernier
ukrainien en leur fournissant des armes
que le rapporte il ya des pertes part et
d'autre non je pense donc que le fait de
se rendre à ce cimetière mémorial
confirme une fois de plus que nous ne
voulons pas de guerre et que nous n'en
avons pas du tout besoin ce qu'il impose
surtout en occident poursuivre leurs
propres objectifs mercantiles quant à
nous nous devons en démontrant la vérité
historique faire passer le message
encore aujourd'hui qu'un tel déroulement
des événements ne nous convient pas
malgré tout le processus diplomatique
suit son cours sergey lavrov a pris acte
de la réponse écrite de washington et de
l'otan la semaine dernière en faisant
savoir qu'elle pouvait servir de base à
des discussions mais sur des thématiques
secondaire car le coeur des demandes de
moscou à savoir l'arrêt de l'extension
des limites de l'alliance atlantique n'a
pas reçu de réponse favorable le
ministère des affaires étrangères a
d'ailleurs envoyé un courrier à l'otan
mais aussi à l'eau est ce leur demandant
comment il comptait renforcer leur
sécurité sans que cela se fasse au
détriment de la sécurité des autres une
question clé qui conditionnera à n'en
pas douter la suite du dialogue
diplomatique
boris johnson actif donc dans le dossier
ukrainien et s'il est à la manoeuvre au
niveau international sur la scène
nationale il est empêtré dans une série
d'affaires embarrassantes le scandale de
soirée illégal a donné à downing street
mais pas seulement sans rature bon
décidément boris johnson collectionne
les polémiques
de nouvelles révélations cette semaine
sont encore venus accabler le premier
ministre britannique
il est maintenant soupçonnée d'avoir
facilité le sauvetage d'un chenil à
kaboul en août 2021 alors qu'au même
moment la ville tomber aux mains des
talibans et que des milliers d'afghans
tentait de fuir le pays jeudi lors d'un
déplacement sur un site industriel dans
le nord du pays de galles boris johnson
a été interpellé par un journaliste sur
cette affaire
tout cela est complètement absurde je
suis très fier de ce que nos forces
armées ont fait pendant l'opération
pitching c était incroyable de pouvoir
évacuer 15000 personnes de kaboul comme
nous l'avons fait les militaires ont
toujours donné la priorité aux êtres
humains et c'était normal je pense que
nous rions être incroyablement fier de
l'opération picking et de ce qu'elle a
accompli
une polémique qui s'ajoute au énième
rebondissement dans la sphère du parti
gates et fête privée organisée en plein
confinement à la résidence du premier
ministre
cette fois c'est la police qui suscite
l'indignation
après avoir demandé vendredi la censure
d'éléments clés figurant dans un rapport
sur ce scandale face à la polémique
boris johnson a dû démentir que son
gouvernement cherche à retarder la
publication de ce document
absolument pas mais vous allez voir j'en
ai peur laisser les enquêtes
indépendantes se poursuivre
quelques heures plus tôt lors de la
séance hebdomadaire au parlement il
faisait face aux critiques de
l'opposition
après avoir rejeté toute idée de départ
boris johnson a botté en touche
préférant évoquer la reprise économique
ou encore la crise en ukraine
monsieur le président ce que je peux lui
dire c'est que nous devons laisser le
rapport aux enquêteurs indépendants
lorsque je le recevrai je ferais bien
sûr exactement ce que j'ai dit entre
temps je pense que ce que les citoyens
de ce pays veulent entendre c'est ce que
nous faisons pour nous attaquer aux
problèmes qui nous concernent tous à
savoir régler le coût de la vie monsieur
le président aider les gens dans tout le
pays
un discours qui n'a visiblement pas
convaincu tout le monde
quoi qu'il vise dans sa déclaration
aujourd'hui ou demain cela ne changera
pas les faits qui sont que ce premier
ministre et son gouvernement n'ont
montré que du mépris pour la décence
l'honnêteté et le respect qui
définissent ce pays
alors que sa popularité est en chute
libre boris johnson et même lâché par
des députés de sa propre majorité et la
récente levée des dernières restrictions
sanitaires vu par certains comme une
tentative de diversion n'y change rien
législatives anticipées au portugal avec
un taux de participation en milieu
d'après-midi à
45,66 % longtemps présenté comme favori
dans les sondages le parti socialiste
d'antonio costa est désormais face un
grand rival le parti
un social démocrate de l'ancien maire de
porto la droite souverainiste pourrait
aussi faire une percée l'actuel premier
ministre soit on retrouve cerné tony
pitaro
[Musique]
le premier ministre socialiste portugais
va t-il rester au pouvoir en place
depuis 2015 antonio costa a longtemps
été favori mais sondage après sondage
l'espérance d'une victoire s'est éloigné
peu à peu à tout pour antonio costa la
vaccination qui couvre 90% du pays et
qui en fait un des premiers pays au
monde en matière de couverture vaccinale
nous sommes arrivés aujourd'hui à avoir
le meilleur taux de vaccination au
niveau mondial il y à 4,5 millions de
portugais qui ont la troisième dose d
entreprises qui produisent plus l'emploi
qui continue à croître le salaire
minimum qui augmente on va augmenter les
retraites baisser les impôts et malgré
tout on va continuer à baisser notre
déficit et notre dette oui ensemble nous
allons y arriver
des élections anticipées
antonio costa ayant vu son projet de
budget 2022 retoqué par la coalition au
pouvoir son principal opposant le centre
droit de rio le parti social démocrate
qui avait obtenu 79 élus lors des
dernières élections contre 108 pour
antonio costa sur les 230 sièges qui
composent le parlement le psd qui compte
créer la surprise
[Musique]
il n'y a qu'une alternative est cette
alternative c'est la social démocratie
qui défend la justice sociale la
solidarité la tolérance qui défend
l'égalité des chances ce sont celles là
nos valeurs
le ps n'a pas réussi à contredire nos
propositions le ps a opté pour le
mensonge pour détourner ce que sont nos
propositions afin d'inculquer la peur
chez les gens et prévaloir le mensonge
le scrutin loin d'être joué d'avancé
même si certains portugais imagine la
victoire du parti socialiste possible
nam nam khao
selon moi je pense que costa va gagner
le parti socialiste ce ne sera peut-être
pas avec la majorité mais il va gagner
parce que malgré la situation de
pandémie dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons je pense qu'il n'a pas si mal
travaillé c'est ce que je pense
[Musique]
je ne pense pas que costa va avoir la
majorité absolue mais il devrait gagner
normalement avec un petit écart de
points seulement mais sans majorité
en 2019 antonio costa avait remporté des
élections grâce à une alliance
historique avec les partis de gauche un
scénario qui pourrait se reproduire avec
un scrutin qui s'annonce serré les
petites formations pourraient jouer un
rôle de faiseurs de rois à l'instar du
parti populiste chega mené par andré
ventura qui ne compte qu'un seul député
qui pourrait connaître une croissance
importante à l'issue du scrutin
au burkina faso une mission
ministérielle de la cedeao sera sur
place dès demain actuellement c'est une
délégation de responsables des armées de
l'organisation qui est à ouagadougou
elle demande la libération du président
renversé par un coup d'état militaire et
placé en résidence surveillée le
président kaboré très critiqué par la
population il est jugé inefficace dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme
françois tessier beach
comme tous les matins à zara prend son
vélo pour se rendre à son travail
depuis février dernier elle et ses
collègues ne reçoivent plus leurs trente
cinq mille francs cfa mensuels environ
53 euros de la mairie de ouagadougou
pourtant il continue d'aller nettoyer
les rues de la capitale burkinabé
gratuitement alors aujourd'hui
tous espèrent du changement avec
l'arrivée du nouveau pouvoir
monsieur roch kaboré il nous a pris
comme des ex clave il nous traiter comme
des prisonniers
douze mois son salaire au burkina faso
ici il veut que nous devenions des
bandits des jihadistes on ne sait pas
des forces de défense et de sécurité a
ainsi décidé de mettre fin au pouvoir de
monsieur roch marc christian kaboré
lundi des soldats prennent le siège de
la radiotélévision burkinabé et annonce
un coup d'état à la tête du pays depuis
2015 le président roch marc christian
kaboré est renversé dans les rues de la
capitale des rassemblements spontanés se
forme
été encouragés et
le mouvement
ils ont sauvé
depuis des mois la population reproché à
roch marc christian kaboré de ne rien
faire pour endiguer la spirale de
violence attribués à des groupes armés
djihadistes affiliés à al qaïda et au
groupe etat islamique
des attaques qui ont fait plus de 2000
morts et comptera au moins un million
cinq cent mille personnes à fuir leurs
foyers
jeudi dans son premier discours à la
nation le nouvel homme fort du burkina
faso le lieutenant-colonel damiba promet
de rétablir la sécurité et un retour à
une vie constitutionnelle normale damiba
qui demande aussi l'aide de ses
partenaires internationaux
as un moment particulièrement difficile
pour notre pays le burkina faso a plus
que jamais besoin de ses partenaires
c'est pourquoi j'appelle la communauté
internationale
à accompagner notre pays afin qu'ils
puissent sortir le plus rapidement
possible de cette crise pour reprendre
sa marche vers le développement avec une
veine de ce match
le lendemain vendredi le burkina faso
est exclu de la communauté des états
d'afrique de l'ouest lors d'un sommet
virtuel convoqués en urgence les membres
de la cedeao exige la libération du
président renversé placé depuis en
résidence surveillée et des autres
responsables arrêtés là c'est bien
honnête n'est pas la bienvenue à aubry
qui n'a pas ce qui a eu des situations
où la cedeao pourrait intervenir et en
parlant de la sécurité il ya plus elles
ont établi des années que nous souffrons
de 7 et sécurité la mêlée l'acid house
n'est pas intervenu mais la cie et avec
ces militaires il peut nous aider à
récupérer cette sécurité l'a
à nouveau sommet de la communauté des
états d'afrique de l'ouest est prévue
jeudi prochain à accra
l'organisation se prononcera sur
l'opportunité d'autres sanctions comme
elle l'a déjà fait pour la guinée le
mali deux autres pays où des militaires
ont récemment pris le pouvoir
la direction la république démocratique
du congo où la situation humanitaire se
détériore dans l'est du pays bon nombre
d'habitants sont obligées de quitter
leurs villages face aux attaques du
mouvement m23 explication serrée louis
assurer les repas pour tout un camp
c'est le nouveau quotidien d'aziza
depuis quelques jours la jeune femme
comme tous les habitants de son village
ont fui leurs terres devenues le théâtre
d'affrontements violents entre l'armée
congolaise et des groupes armés rebelles
dans le territoire de rutshuru au
nord-kivu dans l'est du pays des
villages entiers ce vide face à la
menace
nous étions dans nos champs arruga ri
quand nous avons entendu des détonations
d'armes lourdes et légères des rebelles
était sur une colline et les soldats en
dessous dans la plaine du coup nous
avons décidé de fuir avec nos enfants et
nous nous sommes retrouvés ici à kibumba
nous n'avons rien pris comme biens de
valeur dans notre débandade dans ce camp
de fortune organisée dans l'urgence des
familles déplacées sont contraintes de
vivre dans l'insécurité alimentaire et
humanitaire
nous passons la nuit à la belle étoile
depuis trois jours nous mourrons de faim
et nous manquons même d'eau pour boire
personnellement je porte le même avis
depuis trois jours c'est comme ça que
j'ai fui même chose pour mes enfants
nous avons fui dans la panique il n'y
avait aucun moyen de prendre quelques
miettes va l'heure nous n'avons même pas
de matelas ou de nattes pour dormir un
peu paisiblement
nous avons fui les rebelles en ont
profité pour piller tout nos biens je
n'ai rien emporté avec moi même pas à ma
bi nous apprenons même que tout est déjà
pillé
là nous n'avons aucune autre issue même
s'il vous rentrons nous n'allons rien
retrouvé dans nos maisons nous en font
très peur
cette peur ce sont les m23 qui
l'alimentent des groupes armés composés
de congolais tutsi pourtant dissous en
2013 depuis octobre dernier ce mouvement
est accusé par les autorités du pays de
nombreuses attaques contre l'armée si
depuis ce jeudi le calme semble être
revenu sur place des responsables
demandent l'aide d'organisations
humanitaires
c'est une situation qui nécessite une
attention particulière regardez ce n'est
pas la première fois qu'elle est
quelqu'un se trouve dans cette condition
est donc il faudra qui est vraiment
n est trop inégal da et vigilants pour
que cette population retrouve d'abord
hellip et total sa tête cédait 2,2
qu'elles soient assistés pour le moment
seuls des militaires ont été déployés
dans la zone depuis ce jeudi des casques
bleus onusiens ont installé des bases
temporaire pour prévenir toute nouvelle
attaque reste à savoir si la mission de
l'onu en république démocratique du
congo sera suffisante pour apaiser les
tensions
emmanuel macron s'est entretenu hier
avec son homologue iranien ibrahim
murray ici au coeur des pourparlers les
négociations sur le nucléaire iranien et
gayraud ici m'avoir montrer son sérieux
dans le cadre de ces discussions et
exige toujours la levée des sanctions
manuela macro lui demandent à l'iran de
respecter ses obligations et appels à
l'accélération des négociations qui
piétinent toujours
sur l'accord nucléaire de 2015 le
président de la république a réitéré sa
conviction qu'une solution diplomatique
est possible est impérative et marqué
que tout accord nécessitera des
engagements clairs et suffisant de
toutes les parties auxquelles la france
travaille avec l'ensemble de ses
partenaires
la situation sanitaire en france et ces
quelques chiffres plus de 330 mille
nouveaux cas de kobe dans 24 heures un
niveau élevé mais qui confirme la
tendance récente à ne plus progresser l
santé publique france annonce même que
les contaminations au tâtant le plateau
attendu par les autorités sanitaires la
baisse certes lente se poursuit aussi
dont les services de soins critiques les
animations accueille en ce moment un peu
plus de 3600 la passion qu vide et
sachez qu'à partir d'aujourd'hui
l'injection d'une troisième dose de
vaccin anti qu'ovide est obligatoire
pour les soignants mais aussi pour les
pompiers on en a parlé justement avec
eric brocardi de la fédération nationale
des sapeurs-pompiers de france
aujourd'hui les sapeurs pompiers c'est
une intervention de secret cette seconde
donc une intervention toutes les sept
secondes au contact de la population on
se doit d'être protégé pour protéger les
autres aussi donc aujourd'hui on
constate une chose simple c'est que avec
l'action de la vaccination et cette
campagne de vaccination qui a été menée
les serveurs conclu aujourd'hui on
vacciner 25 % de la population française
donc près d'un quart voire même plus
d'un quart de la population donc on se
devait déjà d'une part de rester dans la
continuité du schéma vaccinal pour
maintenant être pleinement est toujours
associé à cette vaccination est à la
poursuite on va dire de l'armement des
vaccinodromes des maxi bus des unités
justement mobile pour permettre à l'oea
période de faire la vaccination en plus
loin dans tous les territoires il s'agit
aujourd'hui de pouvoir continuer à être
non seulement le premier rempart mais
aussi l'exemple en ce qui concerne cette
obligation vaccinale qui pour l'ensemble
de la population nous permet enfin de
voir le bout du tunnel
cette obligation vaccinale pour
certaines professions le pass vaccinale
des restrictions sanitaires qui ont fait
l'objet de manifestations à travers
toute la france hier aujourd'hui c'est
la belgique qui a vécu au rythme de la
mobilisation anti restrictions
manifestation cet après midi hier
bruxelles la marche des libertés qui
dimanche dernier a dégénéré
l'affrontement entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre les autorités ont donc
beaucoup surveillez cette journée siens
et le canada imposé l'obligation
vaccinale pour franchir la frontière
avec les états unis opération coup de
poing des camionneurs qui bloquent le
centre d'ottawa jusqu'à la levée des
contraintes ils ont été rejoints par des
milliers de personnes samira chaabi
les abords du parlement canadien occupé
sur ces images des milliers de personnes
opposées aux restrictions sanitaires
exige le relevé partie de l'ouest du
pays la semaine dernière les camionneurs
ont inauguré la protestation
les raisons de ce mécontentement
une mesure qui impose la vaccination aux
travailleurs transfrontaliers du canada
et des états unis un convoi qui a reçu
le soutien d'une partie de la classe
politique
c'est un grand jour et je crois que nous
allons gagner cette bataille parce que
la vérité gagnera toujours est désormais
les gens comprennent que toutes ces
mesures draconiennes ne sont pas basés
sur la science ne sont pas basées sur
les faits ne sont pas basés sur la
logique ne sont pas basées sur le bon
sens il est temps d'en finir et c'est
pour cela que ces camionneurs sont
présents aujourd'hui et je veux les
remercier
baptisé convoi de la liberté par les
routiers le mouvement s'est au fil des
jours attiré la sympathie de nombreux
canadiens
ce convoi est une question de liberté ce
n'est pas seulement pour les conducteurs
de camions c'est aussi pour chaque
personne vous - tout le monde tour peut
hein porte il s'agit de votre liberté de
choix c'est de cela qu'il devrait s'agir
comme je l ai dit si vous êtes vacciné
cool vous l'avez fait la plupart des
gens l'ont fait à cause du travail mais
vous devriez le faire par libre arbitre
suivant votre propre choix
nous sommes venus ici pour soutenir la
cause une meilleure vie pour nos enfants
les enfants de nos enfants pourquoi les
choses redeviennent normales les choses
ont duré trop longtemps comme ça il faut
que ça s'arrête
le mouvement a pris de l'ampleur et a
mis les autorités en alerte suite à des
messages de haine sur les réseaux
sociaux ou des menaces proférées à
l'encontre de journalistes
les forces de l'ordre craignaient des
débordements au final rien de tout cela
en fin de journée les autorités ne
faisait état d'aucune arrestation
le premier ministre justin trudeau à
l'isolément pour raison de co lead a
quant à lui évoqué une minorité non
représentative des canadiens chiffres à
l'appui selon lui 90% des routiers sont
déjà vaccinés
retour en france le résultat de la
primaire populaire vient tout juste de
tomber et c'est la favorite christiane
taubira qui est déclarée gagnante
l'ancienne garde des sceaux de françois
hollande reconnaissait la légitimité de
ce scrutin contrairement à trois de ses
rivaux dont cette initiative citoyenne
yannick jadot anne hidalgo et jean luc
mélenchon
et si le peuple avait le pouvoir de
décider pour lui même un voeu qui
résonne à la proche de l'élection
présidentielle à dépend que des citoyens
ont voulu se rapprocher de candidats
prônant la consultation populaire pour
légiférer et d'illustrations à saint
clair du rhône avec yves ollivier d
un scrutin avant l'heure même s'il ne
concerne pas l'élection présidentielle
enfin pas directement car ce vote
organisé à l'initiative d'habitants de
cette commune iséroise doit déterminer
si le maire de la ville peut tout donner
son parrainage à clara et guerre en
feignant à la recherche de soutiens pour
se lancer dans la course à l'elysée
soutenir un candidat un acte que trop
d'élus négligent ce n'est cet
organisateur nous on fait ça surtout
parce que en 2010 7 72% des maires n'ont
pas donné de parrainage pour les
candidats aux présidentielles
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que on
critique les citoyens qui sont
abstentionnistes mais les premiers
absentionnistes c'est les élus justement
quand il s'agit de donner leurs
parrainages et qu'ils ne le font pas
voici peut-être donc les prémices du riq
le référendum d'initiative citoyenne
principal argument de campagne de clara
et guerre revendiquer ici sur son site
internet alors pour montrer l'exemple
aucun détail n'a été laissé au hasard
durant cette consultation on a consulté
100 personnes tirées au sort par un
huissier de justice afin qu'elle réponde
à un sondage comprenant deux questions
du sondage on en voit passer par ci par
là c'est toujours des instituts privés
qui appartiennent à des milliardaires on
ne sait pas vraiment comment ils font
les sondages nous on s'est dit on va
faire quelque chose de citoyens de
transparent et de sécuriser on a mandaté
un huissier de justice qui a procédé
lui-même un tirage au sort est ensuite
on a une urne qui essaient les personnes
cette semaine lucie eon va au porte à
porte toutes les personnes qui ont
participé elles ont dû signaler
largement 1 donc on peut retrouver ces
personnes pour s'assurer qu'elles ont
bien participé et donc le chiffre qui
l'annoncé c'est un chiffre au caire réel
est incontestable demander son avis à la
population pour les décisions les plus
importantes
une idée qui visiblement tir l'adhésion
de plus en plus de monde les sondages
veut pas ce silence aussi bien aux
municipales que régionales
qu au plan national il est j'avais
demandé aux gens est ce que vous seriez
influencé si quelqu'un vous proposer le
risque c'est à dire le pouvoir de
contrôler ce que font les élus c'est
absolument honteux personnellement moi
je voudrais qu'on me demande ce qu'ils
mon avis dans ma dans ma commune quad
ans déjà dans ma commune pour des
décisions qu'ils prennent au niveau
aussi nationale je veux qu'on me demande
j'en ai marre qu'on m'impose des choses
qui sont complètement déconnectés
je veux maintenant qu'on me demande un
souhait qui sera peut-être entendu
puisque certains candidats à la
présidentielle parmi les plus en vues
propose déjà de donner aux français
l'occasion de s'exprimer sur les projets
phares de leur programme
et c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité prochaine édition dans un
peu plus de trente minutes et vous serez
en compagnie de stéphan le mons une
excellente soirée sur la défensive
et
[Musique]
un certain nombre de journalistes
semblent s'est octroyé un pourboire de
juger un pouvoir même de condamner c'est
extrêmement dangereux parce que moi
j'aime savoir d'où parle les gens
cherchent et j'ai su tout et des
réponses mais l étrave ainsi jamais à
oger une qualité ou une compétence ou
une expertise ans et je n'avais pas je
pense que notre métier devrait un peu
douté de ses bases et les revoir et les
remettre en question aurait un rôle
historique pour le meilleur et pour le
pire d'ailleurs parce que si on était un
petit allemands dans les années 30 on
l'a beaucoup entendu hitler et ses potes
à la radio puis toutes les choses graves
j'ai l'impression qu'on les apprend par
la radio quand on écoute la radio on
sait si c'est grave ou si c'est pas
grave plus qu'à la télé
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez comme moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du pt il est
clair que tout le monde attend sable
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux immuniforce quand même des
hommes
comment ces mecs-là arrive à dormir la
nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a vécu
quelque chose d'inusité gilet jaune
c'était des valeurs de droite c'était
des gens qui travaillent c'est les gens
qui avaient envie de transmettre quelque
chose à leurs enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on